this is Jonathan Ferguson the keeper of
firearms and artillery at the Royal
armories Museum in the UK which houses a
collection of thousands of iconic
weapons from throughout history and this
week he's taking a look at the weapons
from sci-fi shooter atomic heart well we
had to have an AK and here it is looking
completely stock the first impression is
pretty good but you'd hope that again
coming from Russians would have a good
AK let us know what other games or guns
you'd like to see Jonathan break down
and make sure to subscribe for more of
this kind of content on the channel
including Loadout which takes an
in-depth look at the most iconic
firearms in gaming right let's take a
look at the weapons from atomic heart
Makarov PM classic of the Cold War and
still used today
um in in Russia and other Eastern
European countries it's not spot on for
a Russian or Soviet made Makara uh then
again neither is this this is a um
Akiba made
macaron it's actually marked on this
like uh Tashkent which I think is the
model it's got a spurious serial number
Spirits Arsenal Mark but it's really
very well made very well finished it has
the standard Soviet type plastic
wraparound grip with the star which this
game version doesn't this has a like a
thumb Groove set of wooden rips I can't
think of a Makarov that had wooden grips
the gun looks a little too or is a bit
too big it's modeled too big I don't
know if you can tell from the size of
the gun versus my hand but there's far
too much bulk at the back especially but
the slide is Too Tall another another
issue is so the real macro of Macaro has
a heel release as it's known as in the
heel of the grip which is really quite
awkward you have to push it to the rear
to then be able to pull out the magazine
now the real magazines do have these
long witness holes in in the sides and
the magazines is depicted don't have
them in necessarily the same place but
that it's it's close enough the problem
with that is you cannot do the um what's
become known as the the John Wick thing
where you press the magazine release and
flick out the gun and use gravity
inertia whatever to to send the empty
magazine away to then present the gun
for the fresh one you can't do it well
you could but you'd have to press the
magazine release pull it part way down
then flick it out which is not what we
see done equally they haven't redesigned
it for a thumb or finger magazine
release uh it's not clear to me where
the magazine button actually is magazine
catch
[Music]
oh dear I I thought I was looking at
gameplay where we'd switched to another
weapon for some reason but no this is in
fact the upgraded uh mackerel and it has
let's start with the positives he has
the traditional plastic grip wrap around
it even has the the separate steel
lanyard on it so that that's that's
pretty good uh the rest of it yeah not a
fan
we've somehow replaced the whole well
part of the frame and all of the slide
and Barrel assembly with something more
like a machine pistol design I mean the
upgrade to the macro PM that's what I'm
concerned is a sketch King a real gun
full auto mackerel kind of design cues
but bigger and more powerful and very
testing and historical this is called an
official foul it has the additional
upgrades that the game has as part of
its
economy has it worked and to be fair I
guess to incorporate that they've had to
re change they've just had to change the
architecture of the gun not sure what's
going on with the magazine that's
obviously extended but also changed in
design and there's something hanging off
the back where in reality the magazine
release catch
lives
[Music]
yeah
the the Russian
ks23 uh six or four gauge shotgun
depending on who who you believe 23
millimeter basically essentially it's a
conventional pump action shotgun it's
just very large ball and has a
distinctive look it makes a lot of sense
in this in this game for for obvious
reasons what I'm looking at here has
been extensively modified with some
stuff some kind of electrical component
tree there's even a nail hammered into
the butt stock there too as a cable
router a big slot cutting about stock to
fit I don't know what's not sure what
that is but again it looks electrical I
also don't know what the big bulky thing
on the front is so I'm going to stop
speculating and see how it performs
before we go
so I've identified I did identify the
attachment point Port thing correctly
not a huge achievement but nonetheless
and there are these files of some sort
of Goo of different types but for
different additional effects that you
can you can attach I suppose I'm not
subjectively I'm not a massive fan of
building similar effects into the gun
that make it more of a fantasy thing but
some people I'm sure are going to enjoy
the combination of real technology with
weird stuff yeah I like the idea of
Legacy weapons that get upgraded in some
way I like that to make some
technological mechanical scents more so
more so than what we have here because
by and large this is behaving just like
the gigantic pump action shotgun that
that it is the other modification that's
been done here this is somehow turning a
pump action to into a semi-automatic the
idea that you can attach something to an
in-game weapon and it just completely
changes the mechanical properties of
that object obviously that jams in my
brain slightly
you're free to overlook it and welcome
to do so but it's always going to irk me
in the back of my brain
change of pace now we have an energy
weapon and I think the comparisons with
this game that have been drawn are
Bioshock of course but also Fallout so
almost like a Soviet Fallout and so far
this is by far the falloutiest of
weapons well well models with with
realistic looking electrical wires and
connections and capacitors and and stuff
like that we've got somewhat
conventional firearm aspects as well so
a grip frame uh what looks like a sheet
metal trigger the blue tape wrapped
around the grip as always annoys me
because unless the grips are badly
cracked why would you do that I suspect
that's an upgrade often grip tape of
some sort is offered as an upgrade in a
game even though it would do very little
iron sights we've got somewhat
conventional Ironsides on top slightly
weird shape I'm not sure you'd bother to
make a front sight out of convoluted
bent sheet metal like that it doesn't
need to be that shape I think that's
more of a is that what I often call
Visual interest thing
right so I think I've effectively
misspoke calling this directed energy
because although it does use electrical
power the main attack is this physical
material it appears to be electrically
charged so it's directing energy as a
weapon but it's not pure energy that
it's projecting if that makes sense
we've got some sort of projectile that
has an electrical current seems pretty
implausible never mind the the idea of
super compact energy weapons anyway
although there appears to be so what
what's built into the gun I think is a
set of capacitors rather than batteries
because it seems to be you seem to be or
maybe rechargeable batteries because you
seem to be charging this weapon from
your own transhuman implants or
something there's some interesting stuff
going on here I haven't fully wrapped my
head around it and then a second attack
with this modified version with the with
the flats on the front is like an EMP
blast kind of thing but EMP is Just
Energy it will it will burn out
circuitry but up things like capacitors
probably but if this seems more
physically destructive than that if that
makes sense
well we had to have an AK and here it is
looking completely stock I'm sure I'll
see an upgraded version soon the first
impression is pretty good but you'd hope
that again coming from Russians would
have a good AK uh I've got one here this
is pretty stock okay um 1974. a little
bit older than me something I did notice
uh the beauty of having access to this
this amazing collection is you can just
pick it up and compare it at exactly the
same angle uh and relative distance from
your face as it is in the game and when
I do that I see that the barrel and gas
tube from the front of the of the
handguards is too short in theory that
means in profile view the whole thing
would actually be a bit too short it's
probably an in-game field of view
perspective for shortening fit uh the
actual model is probably not wrong but
it looks wrong when I hold it in the
same way of render my Pace there's more
barrel and more gas tube here than there
is on the model version I don't know if
it's my speakers but this doesn't quite
sound like an AK to me and it's maybe a
bit slow and chugging I think I think
the firing rate should be a little bit
higher than that oh there's some weird
muzzle flash going on here this is very
small but quite long so it looks it
looks weirdly like a I don't know a
blowtorch or something it doesn't look
like a real muzzle flash and it doesn't
sort of look like your typical video
game it's certainly not your typical
movie muzzle flash which is greatly
augmented by being basically a full
charge blank that just overrides the
capability of any flash suppressor to
suppress that flash
I almost missed that I was focusing on
the Magic Pan but um with one hand off
the gun firing with one hand somehow
we've got the old fudge the reload thing
where it's kind of instead of camera
shot and magazine Off magazine on yeah
and probably you'd have to wrap the
charging handle as well if it's empty
and it's back here back up and ready to
go all without it's like look ma no
hands look ma one hand needless to say
that's been that's been fudged for
gameplay reasons because if you just
always run out of ammo and couldn't
reload well I don't know personally I'd
rather have that and just be reliant on
your magical powers until such time as
you can reload the gun normally
[Music]
foreign
placement top cover Arrangement where we
have those now give you a picatinny rail
on the top this has some additional kind
of electrical magical stuff going on as
the upgraded guns in this game do the
overall impression is a bit Elysium the
film Elysium vintage firearms that have
been upgraded so we have a an additional
four end here a big chamber around the
barrel which now looks super heavy as
well the attachment port for the polymer
material and a huge what looks like a
muzzle brake but I'm guessing it's
supposed to be part of the upgrades not
sure what it's supposed to do a form of
a red dot Reflex sights on top very
vulnerable if that was to get hit by
anything I I can't imagine it wouldn't
break this is why current daily Red Dot
sights are somewhat chunky because they
have to be able to be protected whereas
traditional iron sights just need well
either to be made of a block of steel or
to have some some protectors on the
front
foreign
[Music]
something not very real world of course
quite a strange
rear end on this thing
um I guess it's meant to be a bus stop
but it's shaped more like some sort of
grip weird shape don't really understand
us but well it would work it would work
like a bus stop I just don't know why
it's not shaped more like one but yeah
overall it looks like what it's
purporting to be armored cables
underneath pretty cool there's this cast
metal there's sheet metal pipe work
polymer but looking quite primitive
looking quite cold worry I guess that's
meant to be a sight system on the left
side looks more like an optician's bit
of equipment I will say the I like the
the amount of stuff that's moving and
interacting with itself on the gun it's
hard to do I think it's I think it's
hard to do with energy type super
high-tech weapons that we have no idea
how they would work or even if they
could work but you still have to make it
look and feel like they are working so
the little cylinders that sort of screw
in and out only they react they come in
to fire a shot and so they sort of screw
all the way in slowly for one big
powerful shot and then yeah so those and
the and the the way the the muzzle
device works it does feel like something
that's actually firing
[Music]
okay I think I think we have a well we
have an electromagnetic weapon often
called a railgun I think we can well we
can see this doesn't have strictly
speaking rails it has coils so I guess
technically it would be a coil gun they
are sort of the individual coil
assemblies are shaped so it's almost
like a series of pillars or almost
forming a barrel down the middle I quite
I like the Aesthetics of this thing the
big electricity substation style
component on the top there I don't know
what the big knobbed handle lever thing
on the back of the left side is we'll
find that out it's got a sort of
motorbike grip on the left side let's
have a look
foreign
this seems more more effective than some
of the other weapons I've seen so far a
couple of hits maybe to take out one of
these robots and it sort of seems to
sort of disintegrate them in a low-key
way they're sort of gently floats away
on the breeze like Thanos has snapped
them or something this this is presented
as a sort of coil gun in reality those
things accelerate a physical projectile
to very high velocities and Achieve
damage and penetration that way like a
lot of sci-fi railguns
um video game or otherwise this is more
of an energy weapon so it's charging up
a blast of energy down the coils and
then it shoots down the end so almost
mistaking what
um coil and rail guns actually are this
is more of a directed energy weapon
foreign
[Music]
the visuals on on this on this game
great and there's a lot of variety in
the weapons visually speaking we
everything has that port for attaching
the additional fire effects even this
which appears like it looks like it's
going to be some sort of a rocket rocket
launcher or a coilless weapon or
something looks like we've got three
barrels within this tube I'm not sure
what the big circular Hoops are all
about I'm not sure how you're going to
shoulder this thing there's a sort of
RPG 7 style vertical grip weird sighting
system let's have a look
foreign
ERS but the the munition itself is well
it is a bit like the anti-personnel
rounds fired from something like an rpg7
where there's no Rockets assistance to
the to the Target to give it a flat
trajectory so it just sort of punts off
at an angle law I could sort of shoulder
by mortar the Munitions here they don't
look like anything that I can think of
there they look like miniature mortar
bombs with fins so an upgrade here that
makes sense of the triple barrel aspect
that I spotted where we have a cluster
of three Munitions being loaded in one
go but then they fire individually which
I think would explain why the model I
was seeing had
three holes at the back but only one
hole at the front I'm not quite sure how
that works and then the the sighting
system is is locking on and it the
rocket is traveling really really slowly
toward the target
um Rockets travel significantly faster
than that so despite the lock-on an
awful lot of these shots seem to be
they're spiraling so much I don't know
why they'd be spiraling there's no
reason for for any kind of Rocket or
describe a spin like that that's um
sub-optimal I think it's the phrase and
it and indeed it is in the gameplay
because we've got a solid lock and then
the spiral takes it past the Target that
must be immensely frustrating I don't
know why that's the case it kind of
looks cool but I think if you're going
to have the visual effect of it doing it
you shouldn't really cheat the player by
having this
foreign
thanks for watching guys those were the
guns of the pretty brand new game uh
atomic heart I hope you'll join us over
on the Royal armories YouTube channel as
well lots of interesting videos there
not all firearms related at this point
either although what is Firearms related
is on the 11th of March I am going to be
uh present at a weekend event have a
look on our on our website the details
there under events so again thanks for
watching really appreciate it and we'll
see you next time
foreign
[Music]